[Music]
we've received no no formal or even
informal notification of anything Kim
jong-un had said previously that he
understands the need and the utility of
the United States and the Republic of
Korea continuing in its joint exercises
their exercises that are legal they're
planned well well in advance they're
negotiating over leverage and things
they want to have on a table now our our
diplomats are beginning some insight
into where North Korea is really heading
I think not doing military exercises
would actually be a show of good faith
on our part doesn't change anything
permanently but delaying that until
after talks I think would be a good idea
well reaction to the announcement from
North Korea today that they have a
problem with the u.s. and South Korea
doing joint military exercises so much
of a problem that they may cancel the
upcoming summit June 12th between
President Trump and Kim jong-un that
North Korean statement saying this
exercise targeting us which is being
carried out across South Korea and
targeting us is a flagrant challenge to
the Panmunjeom declaration and an
international military provocation run
encountered to the positive political
development on the Korean Peninsula the
United States will also have to
undertake careful deliberations about
the fate of the planned North Korea us
summit in light of this provocative
military ruckus jointly conducted with
the South Korean authorities so what
about this ruckus and where this leads
and what is it let's bring in our panel
Fox News senior judicial analyst Judge
Andrew Napolitano Philip bump politics
reporter for The Washington Post and
Steve Hilton former adviser to British
Prime Minister David Cameron and host of
the next revolution here on Fox News
Channel Steve it seems like posturing is
this thing falling apart do we think I
don't think it's falling apart I think
that there's a it's perfectly possible
this is part of the choreography
remember that just as what President
Trump is doing is seen here as a big
risk it's also likely that back in North
Korea what Kim is doing is seen as a
risk and he may have people and factions
there that he needs to placate to show
that he's not caving in and so on and
there's this delicate dance that has to
be
to get to that summit I think that the
response from President Trump is going
to be crucial he wants this really badly
I think he's gonna do everything to herd
the cats in a right way to get to get to
that summit you're going it's gonna be
very important to see his response I
think that matters much more than
anything we hear from our diplomats
you've heard Rand Paul Phil say that you
know maybe it's not so bad that we
stopped the joint military exercises
people that the Pentagon's heads would
explode about that because they've been
doing that for a long time they think
it's crucial to the region to continue
to do it well I mean it certainly is
looking several years down the line I
think everyone would like to see a
scenario in which such exercises are
less necessary and that sort of what
we've been working toward but I think
that the point that was just made is it
is a critical point which is that
President Trump has sort of gone against
his art of the deal mentality and put
our cards on the table when his cards
are I very much want this thing to
happen and they think North Korea
recognizes to some extent that gives
them leverage over president trepan over
the United States in this moment to try
and twist some arms and it's because he
knowing the damn trap I mean president
Trump is is not directly said I hope to
win the Nobel Peace Prize but he
certainly is hinted that he reckons it
will be some recognition for this that
gives the North Koreans some leverage
and I think it's also interesting to
note joshua from the Middlebury
Institute has pointed out that North
Korea is also a little incensed at the
way in which the United States is sort
of assumed the ownership over the
developments on North Korean peninsula
or on the Korean Peninsula this may be
also to some extent of reaction of that
listen to martha mcsalley on this
development judge it could be just some
posturing and you know trying to trying
to show strength coming up to the coming
up to the summit but we have also seen
in the past 1992 and 2000 and 2007 where
they had a lot of nice words about
moving towards more of a peace and then
it really ended up being nothing and
they backtracked to their normal
oppressive belligerent regime but the
hard works in front of us basically you
know looking at North Korea's past they
haven't been great about keeping up with
their promises no not at all with
congresswoman mcsalley was here she and
I were talking about this when this news
broke earlier Taylor I don't want to
sound like an echo chamber I agree with
both of my colleagues here and I agree
with her but I wonder
if if our diplomats ought to have known
that this was coming I mean is certainly
Kim knew that these that these exercises
were going to take place Rand Paul is my
dear friend but you're right the
military's heads would explode it's too
late to stop this thing now the cost of
stopping it in in human energy and in
treasure would be would be far too much
and the implication stopping at it would
be so contrary to everything Donald
Trump stands for which is essentially
strength correct correct so either we
didn't know this was coming and we
poorly prepared or this is the way they
are and as Steve says he has to appeal
to his face it's not a nation wide base
it's a very small base of the leadership
of the Communist Party that assures that
he stays in power in the background of
this you have this decision on ZTE this
Chinese company and kind of a walk back
of what we're going to be sanctions
against this I saw on Twitter today
someone speculating that you know maybe
Kim looked at that and said well I want
a piece of that maybe I should ask for
something too if they're walking back
other things I think that's one way of
looking at it I think that the
sophistication of the different players
here is something we can't be certain
about I think the Chinese definitely
feel that as you were saying because the
because the president wants this so
badly they can they've got some leverage
there but in that case that's the
Chinese deal with trade I've been
figuring that that's right but I think
that if that's one dealer it's a very
important one and I was concerned about
the walking back but actually if you
look at the increased scrutiny that
cepheus is giving to deals right across
the spectrum not just this big one but
although you know throughout the range
of Technology deals with the Chinese I
think that the overall the stance
towards China is way tougher than it was
before and I think that needs to
continue but to get this delicate
process on the keeping on on the road
you may need to give the odd concession
here and there so the president know
what Kim is going to say before they
actually meet Singh and Singapore well
that's why Pompeo was out there right I
mean this is a lot of spinning plates
for the new Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo
you'll see what happens